meine damen und herren ich heiße auf
instagram laser luca danke übrigens ein
1,9 millionen abonnenten werden noch
keiner von diesen 1,9 millionen sei dann
wollen wir mal lieber schnell just to
genauso wie zäher jeder andere instagram
user lade auch ich auf instagram bilder
hoch und genauso wie unter vielen
anderen in seinem innern werden darunter
meine instagram bilder kommentare
geschrieben nur manchmal halt richtig
bescheuerte kommentare das heutige video
den sinn dass ich euch diese
bescheuerten kommentare mal vorlesen und
darauf reagieren
jetzt geht es darin
[Applaus]
schickt uns eure perversen beichten wir
posten alles anonym einfach mit alter
und geschlecht per die lieber user mit
dem namen das jüngste gericht
ich möchte dir an dieser stelle wirklich
selbst auch mal etwas beichten und zwar
verpiss dich bitte von meinem instagram
profil luca ich mag dich nicht ich auch
nicht also ich bekomme gabeln und steine
und und naja ist ja auch egal des
schultes mir war es was also ich bin
ganz ehrlich freunde ich bekomme sehr
viele kommentare unserer bilder letzten
22.000 kommentare unter dem bild
allerdings hat es wirklich nicht lange
gedauert solche bescheuerten kommentare
rauszusuchen also da steht eine menge
und warum schreibt ihr so was also wenn
du jetzt nhs pumpen können wir uns
freuen vielleicht kommen die videos
jammer pünktlich [ __ ] euch bei mir ist
es einfach wirklich so immer wenn ich
euch sage irgendwie auch instagram in
den stories oder auch snapshot in den
stories oder irgendwie auf twitter hey
mein heutiges video kommt um 16.15 dann
könnt ihr euch einen weg auf 17 uhr
stellen wie geht meine um einen vorbau
falsch ich habe dich einmal gemacht
warum gemocht weil er früher anders war
als heute
ich verstehe diesen grund einfach nie
ich bin ganz ehrlich freunde meiner
ansicht nach verändert sich jeder mensch
täglich also ich bin nicht mehr der
gleiche mensch
gestern war und ich bin auch nicht mehr
der gleiche mensch der gerade gesagt
habe dass gegenwehr der gleiche mensch
bin der ich gestern war versteht ihr was
ich meine
wir leben in einem raum zeit kontinuum
schwachen bleiben gleich wie
beispielsweise wenn die taschentücher
packung gelegt die gibt es immer noch
allerdings wenn ich jetzt hier sitze und
dann im nächsten moment einfach nicht
hier so mache dann war das ziemlich
dumme aktion aber ich bin zumindest
nicht mehr hier ich hoffe ihr versteht
was ich euch mit meiner summen
physikstunde gerade irgendwie beibringen
möchte aber jeder mensch verändert sich
und wenn sie irgendwie meinen content
gemacht hat von vor keine ahnung zwei
jahren oder so da habe ich vielleicht
noch mehr gaming hochgeladen und das
fand sie dann besser jetzt lade ich ja
mehr wenn das gaming ist dann so was wie
das was gestern kamen
wer wird millionär challenge oder
irgendwie sowas macht mir einfach mehr
spaß und realtech jetzt mal ganz kurz
ich hatte zwischenzeitlich echt sind das
problem dass man youtube einfach kein
spaß mehr gemacht hat weil ich mich
meiner community beziehungsweise meinen
zuschauern anpassen musste was wir sehen
wollten und nicht mich entfalten konnte
schmetterlinge aus der raupe um
zusammenzufassen freunde jeder mensch
verändert sich und ich werde mich auch
weiterhin verändern also es kann sein
dass ich in einem jahr ganz andere
videos hochladen werde ganz andere
instagram bilder und ich hoffe ihr
akzeptiert das einfach weil ich
akzeptiere es auch wenn ihr verändert
also sind wir alle eine schöne große
familie ein lokal der nachdenkt soll die
erp na geh nach hause dugena untreue die
auch aus bei deiner mutter alter hashtag
locker das opfer ich lehne mich jetzt
mal ganz weit aus wie soll ich mich ganz
weit aus dem fenster lehne ich jetzt auf
einen stuhl ich wage jetzt mal zu
vermuten dass dieser kommentar vom user
extra zur hundesteuer geschrieben wurde
falls nicht ist doch etwas wirklich sich
dumm warum macht man ein foto wenn man
schläft punkt um punkt und wie punkt du
blöder vkd abo gegenfrage warum macht
man kein foto wenn man schläft du
schalter wo das ist garantiert nicht
tarif weil deine big band steht dieser
kommentar in unseren foto geschrieben wo
ich neben den big ben in london stand
und in den
in die kätzchen geschrieben habe dass
ich in paris bin also hey scheiße alter
ihr habt mich erwischt ich will so
schlecht sind erdkunde du bist ein
obdachloser nein hier ist nach luca geht
doch nicht so dumm ich weiß nicht wie
man leben kann wie eine kirche in köln
aber hey
anscheinend kann ich mag muffins ist das
normal
da will ich etwas marge gehen du siehst
von oben aus voll behindert aus aber
sonst mag ich dich danke für deinen
geistreichen kommentar so sehe ich von
oben aus also jetzt bin ich anscheinend
behindert laut ihm ich finds auch
allgemeiner fassen wenn man behindert
als beleidigung benutzt also ich mach
das selber einfach wirklich wird
zugegeben auch einfach aus dem effekt
raus so aber ich versuche abzugewöhnen
also freunde und nicht behindert oder
auch schwul oder irgendwie so als
beleidigungen danke du bist ein hasenfuß
scheiße freunde war schön mit euch dass
meine karriere jetzt wohl vorbei der
nächste kommentar wurde unter einem foto
geschrieben wo ich vor einem porsche
carrera gts dasdemir posten zur
verfügung gestellt hat und zwar wurde
darunter geschrieben und keiner darf
fahren hahaha ich bin zwölf aber kopf
hoch
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht wo du wohnst aber
mit 12 darf man noch keine autofahren
ist die ganze ist ein beschissenes
scheiß hart doch lukas hobby ist tobi
stimmt stimmt
deswegen haben wir zwei bamberg hat ja
so lustig gemacht schon traurig dass man
sich selber markieren muss wenn man
davon ausgeht dass die leute die ich
nicht erkennen
die userin heißt luis bester also ich
denke mal was nicht
ich mag mich nicht unter bildern selbst
weil ich denke dass sollte mich nicht
erkennen sondern weil ich denke dass war
warum markiere ich nicht selbst und
haben meinen bildern bin ich denn du
wirst doch zu be me mit deiner ganzen
werbung da muss ich euch tatsächlich
recht geben freunde ich habe in den
letzten beiträgen auf instagram in den
letzten sechs stück oder irgendwie so
habe ich werbung gemacht für
verschiedene dinge allerdings bin ich
jetzt wirklich kein youtuber und da
können wir wirklich glauben der es
wirklich jeden scheiß annimmt ich kann
er direkt jetzt andere kann ich nicht er
bleibt mittagspause wir leben einfach
unfassbar viele anfragen ab die andere
youtuber eventuell tatsächlich
angenommen hätten
ich meine mal ein paar sachen zu nennen
unter meinen letzten gesponserten
beiträgen mit der aok zusammen habe ich
einen podcast gedreht mittels co2 august
meine panikattacken geht eine andere
kampagne die ich letztens auch am start
hatte war bezüglich berufsausbildung mit
dem gummiboot wo leute schauen konnten
okay was ist eigentlich so meine
berufsrichtung eventuell sind meiner
meinung nach wirklich einfach wichtige
sachen und natürlich mache ich dann
dafür auch gerne werbung also wenn ich
jetzt nicht so schlimm aber freunde an
der stelle wenn euch werbung gefällt
folgt mir vor auf instagram typisch luca
fußball echte jetzt sorry hatte aber
fußball das ist doch gar nicht spannend
also finde ich es ist immer der ball da
und kann der der balda okay ich nerve
und da kann es mal wieder ein cooles
video pausen in youtube
schenk mir auch mal ein obwohl die arena
ziehen
nein aber ich habe ganz gute alternative
ich werde die tage noch mal instagram
leicht machen wo ich euch noch mal alles
genau erklären was beim launch diesmal
alles schief gelaufen ist wir hatten
stündlich so 700.000 aufrufe auf die
website also es war schon sehr krass wir
haben unsere server von vier auf zwölf
erhöht wir haben extra dem haus da
gewechselt und bei den sieben lounges
der anderen hollywood shops also auch
von krassen andere youtuber von dehner
und keine ahnung was wem vor mir als
alles glatt laufen bei mir direkt schon
vorm lernt alles abgestürzt es tut mir
leid freunde irgendwann werden wir das
vernünftig hinkriegen ich mache die tage
in instagram leistung da wird dann auch
24 stunden online bleiben auf mein
profil laser luca folgt mich halt doch
einfach habe ich doch gar nicht erwähnt
zum glück werde ich euch sagen woran es
dann nochmal genau lag aber jetzt könnt
ihr auf jeden fall wieder vernünftig
sachen bestellen und die kann man auch
alle vor weihnachten an waffeln keller
typ warum bin ich ein keller typ was ist
ein keller typ a ha ha ha wer bist du
ich glaube das ist der grund warum mit
dem setzt auf bilder mag ihre nacktfotos
sind strafbar deswegen lade ich keine
nacktfotos hoch du bist voll geil da ist
doch chillig wir ergänzen uns perfekt
ich bin keiner du bist neu
lasst uns zusammen kinder machen
du bist auf ein papier
haha was getrocknete bohnen
was sind getrocknete boden dort neben
der coni hat braucht um mit videos mit
ausrasten punkt punkt mit begleiten
punkt um punkt und er lässt das cash
flow banken us geschichte also wählt
eure beleidigungen werden echt immer
kreativer du guckst wie eine
klassenkameradin von mir wenn ich was
sage und sie mich ansieht ich guck dir
eine klassenkameradin von dir
[Musik]
ich bin männlich glaube ich haye kann
ich bitte deine handynummer chrome schon
bitte ich weiß dass katja unter allen
leuten die sich ihren song kaufen ihre
handynummer verlost also da könnt ihr
eine handynummer abstauben aber meine
kriegt ihr nicht ich hoffe ihr versteht
dass ich meine hände immer nur meine
freunde heraus gebe also mama und papa
tatsächlich nur hätte ich das foto
gemacht hätte ich die auf den kopf
gestürzt war meine damen und herren das
ist ja klasse haben mich wirklich als
letzten kommentare wieder ein richtig
richtig meisterwerk rausgehauen wenn sie
das foto gemacht hätte hätten sie mir
auf den kopf gestülpt kohl freut mich
mega an der stelle du solltest auf jeden
fall neuer fotograf werden
das war sich von ihm eine davon herren
ich wollte einfach mal wieder auf ein
paar instagram kommentare von euch
reagieren ich werde gerade so schnell
und ich arbeite haben heute von mir mal
einen rap-song sehen lassen einfach kein
like da werde ich ihm dies ist das rot
wenn ihr in die nächste folge luca
reagiert doch dumm instagram kommentare
kommen wollt dann lasst mal ein abo
darauf meine instagram profi ich habe
mir gedacht ich habe es noch gar nicht
im heutigen video erwähnt deswegen
könnte ich mir das was jetzt hier
video das was jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt jemand den kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten meinen job ausschenken
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
managen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]